every day I work is every day I'm like
screaming on the inside because it's
like I should not be doing this this is
not what I want to be doing I'm being
pulled to something completely different
so every day becomes harder the more I
immerse myself in my coaching and
learning about this business and how I
can create an impact every day it's even
harder to log in and do my six hours
it's just at this point it's
excruciating how can I get out of here
as quickly as possible the immediate
opportunity is figuring out how do we
replace our salaries this is where a lot
of people get stuck at the beginning I
love these people and they're so good
like I didn't want to help and then you
get pulled in to either helping them for
free or doing it like super discounted
rate yes and you feel so fulfilling but
it's like you are not making money we
need to prioritize within our mission
making money so that we can afford to
quit our job and then make more money so
we can afford to hire team to help us
build our brain you have to learn how to
monetize number one is Mission purpose
and then somewhere in two to five has to
be making money
all right Mary in the house what do you
got so Mary's part of mover makers and
uh came in here did the train in the
morning to get her last night yeah be
here and how can I help what's on your
mind so I've been in with movement
makers now for about a month and brand
new brand new brand new yeah and what
I'm doing right now is I'm trying to
build my coaching business so that I can
transition from having a full-time
career to coaching full-time and I think
the biggest obstacle for me or challenge
has been time
having the time to do everything that
needs to be done because there's a lot
it can be very very overwhelming and
right now I'm still working full-time
and so there's a lot less time to do
coaching but I am devoting about four
hours of my day to coaching and building
the business and four hours every day
four hours every day that's pretty good
okay so I thought I thought it was going
to get a lot less to work with more
today is doable okay yeah I mean 4 30
a.m to 6. so I'm like I'm trying to just
do things for you know like my website
trying to get things organized I'm not
coaching anybody obviously that early
but I'm just kind of doing some of the
administrative things
um sometimes it's learning reading you
know finding out what's out there what
could work for me and then from 6 to 12
I'm working in my career and then 12 to
4 I'm back to coaching
um and then and then that's it I mean my
kids get home so
I have that for 12 to four of coaching
plus you're doing time in the morning to
do there's like an hour and a half in
the morning yeah and then there's four
hours in the afternoon okay so yeah so
in total it's about five and a half
hours a day and then I devote my
weekends uh like I would say a good 10
to 12 hours on the weekend towards
coaching so okay trying to kind of build
the hours together to have that
full-time presence yeah but at the same
time like it's that's enough no that's
definitely enough okay how many of the
four hours are you actually coaching
right I'll only do it on the weekend so
um but you could be doing four hours a
day potentially that's a lot of coaching
it's a lot of coaching plus because I'm
up so early and I'm already doing like a
full days of work like I'll take my full
work day and I'll crunch it into six
hours because I'm only giving them six
hours so by the time noon hits and I'm
I'm changing hats that I'm now doing the
coaching stuff I'm exhausted and I and I
do want to bring my best to my clients
so I I don't coach during the week just
because I I do feel a bit depleted
got it so what are you doing in those
four hours in the afternoon then so I'll
be doing things like movement makers
watching the courses
um last month I had a business coach
that was helping me like you know okay
this is your next step this is what you
need to do you know start doing this get
on and then and I'm honestly mostly
learning social understanding how social
Works how do you do your posts how do
you do your reels what makes what
creates the most impact what
um like what platforms can you use where
you're repurposing like there is so much
to learn when you're using social media
as a way of making like building your
business and generating leads there's
there's a lot so then the more time I
spend on that the less time I feel like
I have for coaching because on my
weekends I'm back to learning right yeah
there's so much so first step is how do
we get your coaching business to the
point where you can quit your job yeah
so I do have a deadline I've already
told work that December 31st is my last
day okay so so I have like a eight-month
Runway where I'm gonna have to replace
my income and and use my coaching income
as my my sole income perfect who are the
best types of people for you to coach
like who's an ideal client it's been
evolving because initially like I love
the entrepreneurial space and I follow
so many amazing coaches and
entrepreneurs I tend to really gravitate
to people that are in the personal
development space
um so for me I'd love to coach people
who are on a mission to make an impact
and I'd love to be part of that journey
by coaching them to by ensuring that you
know they've got the momentum they've
got that accountability and we're moving
forward on our goals so that's like one
part of me but at the same time like
even in just coming here yesterday and
taking the train for the first time
let's go I ran into three women who had
similar stories to mine and that they
were you know single parents working
jobs they're having dreams and trying to
figure out how to Pivot from what
they're doing to what they want to be
doing and like one of them
basically told me like
I I love the personal development space
but I don't see someone like you like I
want to relate to a woman to a single
mom who's trying to make things work who
has aspirations as pursuing her dreams
and she even said like and as someone of
color which is something that I've never
even crossed my mind like I want to see
myself in someone that I'm following or
you know someone who's sharing a message
and inspiring me and it got me thinking
because my whole thing is I'm a mindset
coach I'm a high performance mindset
coach and that's where my certification
is from
but at the same time I feel pulled to
their stories because I've come from
similar stories what's the um best thing
you can pull from your career your
current job yeah into this coaching
business
So currently I work for the federal
government for immigration and I'm I'm
like a senior strategic advisor on
management accountability maybe the
accountability portion
perhaps there's not a whole lot of
similarities and and that's sort of why
I'm trying to move because I really want
to be like I'm 14 years away from full
retirement do I want to spend those last
14 years of my career doing this or
do I want to pull the plug and like just
invest in myself believe in my gifts and
just start doing something completely
like there's so much writing on this
decision but I felt like I just need to
make the decision and which is why I've
given my my drop dead deadline on like
I'm out on this date so at this point I
need to make it work but I also need to
make sure that I'm pursuing it with love
and and and the love for the service the
love for making that difference you know
like I want to make sure that when I do
it I'm not doing it for the money yeah
because it doesn't drive me so when you
say believe in your gifts what what
would you articulate as your gifts so
I'm like highly intuitive and highly
sensitive and I feel like and I can
really tap into people's energy like
when I have a conversation with someone
I can sense what's really like what
what's the real story like there's a
story that you think you're telling
yourself but then there's the real story
of like why you're really not where you
are or where you want to be and for me
it's it's it's to help people navigate
their thoughts their beliefs their
emotions so that they can really
understand why they're taking these
actions or not taking any action at all
so for me it's like I want to help you
get real with yourself
you know you you think you're not where
you want to be because of X let's
explore that and help people really just
like dig below the surface of their
thoughts like go right into the
tentacles and really understand where
that even comes from like who where does
that belief come from or who gave you
that belief did you use any of those
skills at the government no do you I
don't no I I don't and that and that's
every day I work is every day I'm like
screaming on the inside because it's
like I should not be doing this this is
this is not what I want to be doing I'm
being pulled to something completely
different so every day becomes harder
the more I immerse myself in my coaching
and learning about this business and how
I can create an impact
every day it's even harder to log in and
do my six hours it just gets it's ended
at this point it's excruciating yeah how
can I get out of here as quickly as
possible but also when I leave like
there's a drop dead data and I won't
leave any sooner because that's my
commitment to them that's fine but it's
like on that drop dead date I don't want
to arrive at a place where I'm feeling
like I'm starting to develop a scarcity
mindset because uh I need there there's
no income coming into my bank account
every two weeks right it's very uh
self-aware to even know that that's
something that because that'll just
creep into the subconscious absolutely
so here's the thing like you've got
you've got a great Vibe I love the
energy I love the personality I think
people will be drawn to you I mean
you're already starting to do it uh even
on the train right here and and you're
just getting started in all of this
right yes the opportunity here is
there's the big long-term opportunity of
you could help whether it's everybody
whether it's women whether the female of
color or whatever that says a lot of
people in
even just North America who need that
yeah the immediate opportunity is
figuring out okay how do we how do we
replace our salary correct because the
the women on the train may not be able
to afford you as a coach right so this
is where a lot of people get stuck right
at the beginning I love these people and
they're so good like you didn't want to
help and then you get you get pulled
into either helping them for free or
doing it like super discounted rate yes
and you feel so fulfilling but it's like
you are not making money right so it's
it's just an order of sequencing so it's
not
that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission
making money
so that we can afford to quit our job
and then make more money so we can
afford to hire team to help us build our
brain so it's like on purpose first yes
you have to learn how to monetize right
right number one is Mission purpose and
then somewhere in two to five has to be
making money if you're an entrepreneur
or you don't make money right so that
becomes now the opportunities okay how
do we take what you do and be able to
monetize it so why I'm asking how can
you connect it to your current workers
because the more we can we can win off
of just your magic which is great which
is like believe in the gifts and then
believe in the magic and people will
feel different being around you and want
to sign up on the spot which is great
and the more we can lean in on any kind
of credibility or history or success
stories or like that's a hard part of
the beginning of a coaching journey is
because
you know if you're not doing it full
time yet and that's right it doesn't
connect to the Java work experience
you've had it's it's like it uh creates
uh resistance to want to hire you
especially at higher rates yes so that's
what we're trying to find is like inside
of inside of your story how can we pull
out some elements that give you more
credibility so that when you're talking
to people uh they'll just want to hire
you on top of the magic well I did get
my professional coaching certification
so I have that it took me 18 months but
because I did it on only on my weekends
so I have that I am currently coaching a
few people on my weekends so there I am
starting to build my experience
um I'm now on social doing videos and
posts and and and what's nice is that in
the caption description you can really
explain things and build that Authority
on who you are and what what you offer
but I definitely haven't gotten to the
point where okay now I need to start
doing some Outreach you know like dming
like I'm not there
I would almost even go
this is fun like okay so certification
is fine
you don't see how long it took you right
nobody cares uh and if it took you
longer than most people then it's even
worse right so like yeah I don't need to
talk about that
uh you're probably not gonna win because
if the focus is how do I get 10 clients
who will pay me
a good amount of money so I can quit my
job right right like how much how what
do we need to be making by January
like to pay my bills well whatever yes
yeah like you're not like scarcity
mindset to the max oh my God I do have
to get another job or keep going yeah
yeah well I mean you're not buying a
Lamborghini no I'm not buying a
Lamborghini but a range no it's okay not
joking but okay I'm kidding I'm curious
I love it doesn't yeah the bigger one I
got big goals though that's good um I
got a house for kids right so I need a
big car so I'm just kidding
um so for me I think I need to be making
at least 10K a month to be able to
sustain my current good correct or a 10K
a month that's our starting point that's
our star Baseline yeah perfect so for
looking at one to two thousand dollars a
month for coaching what are you charging
right now so like what are my packages
or what am I actually charging uh both
okay so my packages are like three
months six months and 12 months so like
that the 12th month is 26 000 so it's
basically 2K like you know it's it comes
to about 500 a session okay it's not bad
okay okay I mean people use it under
yeah under price themselves at the
beginning it's like okay fifty dollars
or set
okay I would go to U.S pricing go to
well because um when I took a program
with ever coach they said like never
charge less than 300 us
um per session so I've tried to kind of
adopt that mentality for yeah it's fine
okay yeah U.S pricing okay and then like
you know I tried to price it and that
like you know pick the middle program so
like you know the first program the
three month is much more expensive the
middle program is the biggest savings
and then the third program is less
savings so because you're always trying
to get someone to kind of pick something
in the middle to feel like that that's
the value so that's so that's what
that's how I have it structured and like
six months is a good amount of time to
actually help someone change right
yeah yeah I mean I might even just
default her annual and then see what
they say annual okay yeah we do it like
yeah annual basis right your prices are
bad so twenty four thousand twenty four
thousand twenty six twenty six seven
yeah right so we just need to find five
clients
that's true that's true yes you get you
get five clients at 25 000 uh well no
then you only need four clients well I
guess sometimes you need 10K a month so
yeah so we need we need no you're right
five clients yeah five clients on an
annual that's not that so it's like we
have a big mission to change the world
right I mean and it's like okay our
immediate goal I need and maybe we hit
that in a couple months doesn't have to
it doesn't have to take the December to
if you have 10 clients who are still
we're happy too right very much so but
the immediate goal is it's not some
crazy thing that you're coming in to say
I need to have right a thousand clients
paying me right yeah so it's five
clients five clients between now and
this December right yeah perfect at a
minimum
so then it's who are the best people who
can afford you yeah to pay two thousand
dollars a month if you're connected with
women then we could find it's women it's
not that you only have to do one but
it's helpful to yeah narrow in on like
the right influences to take you to the
path right so
is it women in careers so I've honestly
mostly been haven't coached any woman oh
I've been coaching men okay
um and it's been the people who I have
been coaching are people that are in the
um like in the fitness space so I have
one that's you know that's looking to
Branch off and build his own facility
and build his own business helping the
youth have have a facility for for
coaching and you know like strength
training and like he wants to have
something like that because it doesn't
exist in the city that he lives in right
um I have another one who's looking to
um Branch off but and who he works with
professional athletes so he's trying to
approve for a service that the
professional athletes will use because
he uses like high-end technology so he
wants to have a business where he offers
the service and he's so both of them are
really trying to get out of their jobs
and Branch out into their own which is
literally what I've been trying to do
I've been helping them in like moving
the needle forward I'm like okay how
what are we going to do today how are we
going to take action what's going to get
us closer to our goals right and that's
like my mindset coaching background of
you know get getting them to really get
crystal clear on what they want why they
want it and what are we going to do to
get there right so that and that I'd
have been enjoying that just because
it's my journey too right it's me trying
to figure out how do I get out of my
career and you know and get into
something that I love something that I
feel like driven to do so how much does
somebody have to make
to hire you for 25k if they're
a salary worker who wants to then go
start their own business
honestly I think that they would
probably have to bake around 200 or 250
to take 10 percent of that and reinvest
it in themselves by hiring approach and
that too
especially in Canada well I just have to
Canada you could do Zoom coaching it's
true yeah yeah it's actually us it is
U.S it is U.S they'll spend more right
Canadians I'm coaching someone like I'm
coaching someone in my city so it's nice
because then I can I do one-on-ones in
person and over Zoom which is really
great I'm also to coaching someone in
Toronto so my mind's sort of in Canada
but you're right the Market's actually
markets in the US you're right person
it this takes too much time yeah I know
for one-on-one unless they're paying
like crazy because you have to either
they come over to your house and then
that's awkward or you go to them or you
go to their a coffee shop or something
but yeah travel time I know that sucks
up your whole day yeah or your four
hours on a Sunday or whatever yeah
that's true so that anyway that's fine
so it's more about figuring who are the
people who have budget who can hire you
or you get paid to
come in to an organization and help them
with their team
exactly honestly like as I think more
about this
it's like how can I create the Maximum
Impact right not yet
okay oh no this is where we get together
yeah exactly this is the Trap Maximum
Impact yeah yeah it doesn't make you
money in the next three years well
that's true and we need we have a drop
dead date December 31st yes yes no
you're right and right yeah so but
that's not the question right now
Maximum Impact we just State impact
right Max of impact on like individuals
but not world oh yes high impact and we
need to be paid to do it so we can
continue to build and scale okay
I think people who are going to be
entrepreneurs is a really hard Market
because they just don't have yeah budget
right and especially if they quit their
job and then they go to start their
business then they have no more money to
pay you yeah so the coaching will
probably end absolutely so it's finding
people who are it could be if you're
making a quarter million plus a year and
you want to start a business yeah you
know I'm good I'm I'm gonna help you and
I would get the 25k up front
nice once they start the business it's
going to be really hard to yeah right
and I collect after every session okay
yeah up front yeah like all of that it
could be potentially negotiable right
could I do quarterly installments could
I do just six months you don't have to
say no to it but you can say like here's
yeah here's here's what we did
or like maybe half up front and then the
rest on a monthly basis like I wouldn't
default to that okay okay
really yeah just default to up front and
then if there's resistance or that
that's really the problem then you can
see how much you even want to be
flexible negotiate around some of these
things okay but it's fine the people who
can drop 25k on working with you who are
those people
who are more corporate where you're
going to come in and do training for
their team yeah that's easier to sell
yeah because it's a business expense
right with pre-tax dollars yeah uh but
it may not be what you want to do either
right like your Hired Gun for RBC to
come in and
you know train their people once a month
or something you know maybe that's not
interesting honestly I'm more drawn to
people that are on a mission
right like people that are on a mission
that are heart centered service driven
they're looking to create an impact I
resonate with those people like I
resonate with the Tony Tony Robbins and
the Ed mylettes and the Tom bilius I
resonate with these people so then it's
looking at who are the people who who
are then already on the mission yes not
starting the mission yes
and again it's just the order of
sequence you're going to help the people
who are starting the mission 100 which
is not yet just not now probably yeah
because to go and find people who are
making a quarter million plus and then
want to quit to go start a job I start
their own business is a
that is doable but it's a rough
path right versus finding already
successful entrepreneurs and
your your game has to be strong to be
able to go and help them totally that's
where the magic right and I think that's
where my
magic abilities comes in and and the
fact that like I have an ability to
really listen deeply to people and what
they're saying and what they're not
saying and really help them you know
like peel back the layers and the things
that they keep telling themselves about
themselves and get into their story and
shift that mindset because you're here
but you want to get to here well the
person you are today is not going to be
the person that's going to get you to
where you want to go like you need to
change your story you need to change
your mindset you need to change many
many things to be able to elevate
yourself to the levels that you want to
be playing at right and that's where the
mindset coaching it's like reprogramming
you know the way you're thinking feeling
behaving and acting to get you in
alignment with not who you are but who
you're becoming and like and that's
where I feel like my gifts really shine
and helping people see their own gifts
and helping them get there much much
quicker you know by just having that
self-awareness and then taking that
certain awareness and putting it into
action right to start seeing different
results
um so I think your best shot is to start
you start a show
okay interviewing entrepreneurs yeah
like ideal clients okay potential ideal
clients or people who can introduce you
to potential ideal clients
[Music]
absolutely yes anything that you're
doing on
Instagram and websites and all that
stuff it's building the brand but it's
probably not going to help you get sales
and it might even hurt you really
okay
I I mean I haven't gone through and look
at your content but you know the
entrepreneurs are
these are high achieving people who
probably have all of their own social
accounts everything set up yeah
and they're if they're looking at your
stuff and and judging you that might be
a strike against versus you're you're
mysterious you're right
yeah it's funny I I did like you know
the business the business death show for
puppet makers so I interviewed Kash of
Khan who is the CEO of the DNA company
you know I did like a 30-minute
interview with him and I posted it and I
absolutely loved it because like I got
to sit down with a brilliant mind yeah
and I think that's why I'm drawn to like
I want to coach these people their mind
okay so what happened what happened like
did you offer him coaching I did an
offer him coaching no So what had
happened was that I took his DNA test
and it gave me these incredible insights
about me it's funny because when he sent
me my report I'm reading this like
massive report and all I see is myself
like literally someone's telling me
about myself like it's so accurate and I
thought how can I leverage this
information about me in coaching if I
was to have a uh someone come on board
and Coach with me yeah me having them do
a DNA test and having them understand
their DNA and how their DNA affects
their actions their behaviors their
moods their decisions like there's so
much information in your DNA that
creates self-awareness and then how do
we utilize all that information in your
personal life in your business sure and
it's just not what we need right now
right
yeah unless your gifts aren't magical
enough to help people
right like if if you can help somebody
then then all those things are bonus if
you want to add DNA company right sleep
tests and whatever else on top of it
yeah cool
but if we don't need that to we don't
need that then then it's it's an
elevated experience to do it our goal
isn't to help sell DNA company services
treasure which I I love them gosh me too
he's amazing right but like our goal is
to sell our stuff right yeah we need to
get our people in right and not worry
about how to sell right his stuff right
yeah so he is a great Target in terms of
these are the people you should be
talking to yes does he know that you're
he does yeah yeah I I said it at the
beginning then I was a mindset coach
great so that's a really good start okay
somewhere in these shows in the
interview
you have to bring up mindset and
coaching you know for example so in my
business here's what I see with
entrepreneurs I I coach successful
entrepreneurs on improving their mindset
to achieve yada yada yada right where
are you seeing that show up with your
clients or where are you seeing that
show up in your data or what are the
genes so like we're tying it back into
you yeah being the mindset expert right
and we're looking for opportunities to
potentially even
like what are your gifts telling you
while you're talking to him
that maybe come up live on the interview
or maybe come up afterwards
well for me it was like I guess I used
the interview for the wrong purpose I
was using the interview to build my
audience of showing people like if you
want to optimize your life yeah like
mindset is also about you know how your
mindset is mentally physically
emotionally and it's like by taking
these insights you can Elevate things in
your life right they can optimize your
sleep by understanding what genes turn
on and off for you you know why why
you're not sleeping so it was like
trying to show people that there's
information out there at your fingertips
if you choose to have it and it's going
to
um completely impact the way you live
your life yeah so who wouldn't want this
information no I mean that's great right
and again just like not what we need
right now exactly exactly but it's worth
thinking about even though you didn't
go down this path with him it's worth
thinking about what actually activated
in you that if he was a client you would
call out
yeah and maybe something comes up right
now or maybe that you know on the train
ride home but huh you know what I
noticed in him I noticed this he kept he
kept talking like this and I think
that's
an area that needs to be improved I
almost need to watch the playback
to really get it like because I guess I
wasn't thinking about he's my target
yeah right I was just thinking he has
information that can help so many people
and I want people to know that he exists
in his Services exists because this will
help people right and that was kind of
that was the place where I was coming
from right but this is a different uh
yeah like and at this point we don't
need to worry about building audience
you're right we need to build a business
yeah and the business allows you to hire
people to help you build the audience
too so now he still may be great because
he who's hiring who how much is DNA
company well I think it's like 500 us
okay so you know people who are buying
that
might be potential clients for you too
right yeah so he could be a client and
his his customers could be clients right
yeah because these are people who
actually care about optimizing their
life so instead of thinking how do you
bundle your stuff or his stuff with you
okay you think how can you bundle your
stuff with him
or anybody like all right that's the
point of the biz Dev show is yeah we
need to Biz Dev we need to generate some
business yeah right so whether it's
talking to entrepreneurs but he's a
great fit in terms of
he's a successful entrepreneur running a
business not oh I work at Royal Bank
right trying to quit my job right right
yeah yeah absolutely so now if you're
talking to one of those people a week
on your show right where either they
could be clients or they know someone
who could be clients yeah
and you're showing your gifts on the
show right something will happen because
of that okay and we only need five
clients right and so do one show a week
at a minimum like I don't know how hard
you want to hit it but if I'm you I
actually scale back everything else okay
to devote maximum time to the show
okay your website doesn't matter your
Instagram stories don't matter good
because they're time consuming yeah well
like I mean and that's like it doesn't
matter just not yet yeah exactly all of
those things are skills to learn the
ability to make a 15 second piece of
content that that hits is a good skill
to learn that will suit you for life yes
right now
yeah it's not the skill to learn just
like yeah talk to the DNA company about
selling it to your clients or whatever
is a good skill it's a good add-on but
just not right not yet so it's just a
sequence it's not that you're doing it
wrong it's just the wrong order exactly
you hit the nail on the head right it's
the wrong order
and so that's 100 that's where a lot of
people are saying I want to have a big
impact I want to it's like yes and like
the way to do this to monetize so that
you can build a team so that you don't
enough for that other job in January
right yeah we're creating a job for
myself doing these things yeah no and if
you're doing early morning like that
opens up Europe so that could be a show
it's just people in Europe that's true
there's a lot of people who might be
able to you know they connect with you
yeah this big Market there or if you
want to use that time to to do your
Outreach right
and then I'd be looking at the four
hours afterwards
you might need to take an hour to sleep
or meditate or like if you're exhausted
afterwards then those four hours are
useless that's yeah so what's your like
you work from home I work from home yeah
it's like when you have a job and you
come home there's like a there's a drive
there's a wind down there's a transition
exactly right and like turn off that
screen turn on that screen yeah so
create your own transition yeah go have
a bubble bath like whatever you're
thinking do some yoga yeah get outside
get some fresh air whatever the thing is
for you that so that you're not showing
up tired right it's better to be
refreshed for three hours than burnt out
for four honestly if I've even been
thinking about like why don't I reverse
my schedule where I get to do coaching
first in the morning and then do my work
because it's like my prime time is I'm
an early riser so like that is when I'm
most creative that that is when I'm most
like you know tuned in Tapped on like I
am productive so maybe I need to even
just reverse the order of the way I'm
working play with it yeah yeah and then
and then the other thoughtful transition
is then how do you transition from the
work to your kids so that you're not
burnt out for them too oh yeah I know
I'm I'm on like 17 hour schedules every
day and then I invest in my weekends
like I like I do the gym I go to the gym
and everything like that but it's like
it's just the time that you have how do
you maximize it yeah to get you the
fastest results absolutely right so all
of the all of the clip stuff like it's
great it's practice but it's not that's
not going to help you
most likely go close your clients our
five ideal clients yeah anytime soon
right long term yes when you're building
a brand where you're building your
courses where you need your speaking
gigs or you're writing your book oh like
that's and that's all in my mind right
like that's right because if all you did
was coach five people then it's not a
compelling Vision to pull you forward
all of those things pull you forward
it's just again the sequence the order
is wrong right so
I would stop all of that stuff okay
and just focus on your show stuff and
meeting people yeah like getting ideal
clients so
however you found Kashif and then other
people yeah whether you're looking up
the Inc 5000 list or the profit 100
lists or whatever it is like the fastest
growing companies elements okay both Inc
and and profit they do lists right of
people submit their numbers and it shows
how quickly they're growing year over
year it's called Inc Inc 5000. okay
profit that's just what it did when it
was in Venture Capital yeah I just went
to the profit list the KA list yeah and
that you see how much they're growing
and message them hey you need venture
capital
thank God on calls like those are your
ideal clients but you're not going to
say hey you need a mindset coach he's
like hey I'd love to interview you
I'm I'm starting a new show about
mindset and how it impacts entrepreneurs
I'd love to have you on and they're
looking for PR because they've submitted
their own numbers to be on these
Publications okay right and some people
say yes you know it's like Chicago said
yes without yeah without I had like I
don't know 100 like not even 200
followers and it's like but I but I love
that because that's someone who's not
looking at the numbers and not looking
like wants to share this message wants
to share the story exactly here's the
thing now go look at everybody who
follows Kashif yeah on Instagram okay
see what their companies are too okay
they might be guests right you could say
I had cash if oh yeah cash iPhone
I know who that is other people are like
who's cash I've never heard of this guy
right go to his following so go to
people but they have to be ideal clients
like you look at their accounts and you
see what they're doing but because
you're probably not going to win at this
point with your Instagram content
because if you're going after successful
entrepreneurs their content is probably
better than yours yes it is and so then
they're judging you for that right but
that's not how you're winning right now
that's not like that's the gift you're
developing not the gift that you have
and we're selling the gift that you have
yeah right now
and so that so how do you get the gift
how do you experience it well I need
let's get on a call like let's do a show
so they get to be in your magic and then
it's the boldness so that's like the
strategy so okay so strategy right we're
gonna make a list of all the ideal
clients or referral Partners that's
right to bring people in who can afford
to drop 25 000 a year on coaching with
you okay we're gonna do a weekly show if
you can do more or you do more if you
can do three times a week do three times
a week it's really about booking booking
the people right yeah once you're on
natural and if you're not doing all the
other stuff exactly then you have more
time to research people and and send
messages oh yes so Inc Inc 5000
profit 100 uh people who follow the
people who you've already had on yeah so
that becomes this guy this trend and
then
yeah we spend as much time as possible
at reaching on the show
like you don't even need to have a
website like it may be better to have no
website than really
I just finished my website
I don't like it so you think about who
your ideal client it's not just some
person I was leaving a corporate job who
doesn't know anything about brand if I'm
an entrepreneurs who probably have a
decent branding yes they do and so they
know judge I don't want them I'd rather
them see nothing that come and look at
you and it looks like it's some homemade
thing yeah so yeah Jeremy I guess you
haven't met these guys yet but Jeremy
Drew Zach or people who I've partnered
with in their businesses starting
YouTube Consulting agencies
uh mid to high six-figure a year
businesses yeah no website no social
media yeah
yeah but they also are not trying to
build like a giant brand around it
either so you're just kick ass at what
you do and you're so good you don't need
a website right
so you can do the Outreach like you
already had you did the hardest thing
you got cash upon
now that he's on you can go get other
people on that's like it's a legit
that's the hardest step is getting
anybody to say yes yeah and it's really
more mental step than anything else
absolutely right A lot of people say I
only have 200 followers he'll never say
yes I said yes it's true and I really
aligned it as like
I saw you on Tom bilio I researched you
yeah I took your DNA test I'm amazed at
my results I want to help you get your
message out there how can I help are you
willing to come and have an interview
with me where I can share you with my
audience yeah and he said sure yeah you
can go after other impact Theory now
that you had cache if you can go after
yeah
but I wouldn't go after mindset people
because you're the mindset right
absolutely you know Karen Jones was on
there he's your friend but he's a
mindset guy right I'm gonna hire you
right that's what he teaches yeah you go
up to the people who are doing yeah the
health stuff for the other stuff yeah
help them but the Instagram is is great
too it just takes a little more work to
go through and one by one identify
do they look like they could afford my
services or not I know and that's and
that's I've thought about that a lot is
like you know like dming dming it's like
okay well you don't want to waste your
time dming people when you don't even
know enough about them on like do they
need the service can I help them do they
have the money like there's like I think
there's smarter service and you can help
them for sure that's yeah right exactly
so it's a bit of a judgment call but if
you're spending your mornings on that
you spend an hour working on the ink
list and then the next day you spend an
hour working on the profit lesson and
next time it's been an hour working on
impact Theory guests and then the next
day you work an hour on uh DMS for
people who are following Kashif right
right right as a starting point
absolutely something will start the work
yeah right and some other stuff won't
work cool but if all the energy is going
into the show that's the strategy okay
that will get you fastest path to making
money right the heart so that's like the
head the heart is you need to lean in on
the magic when that moment comes
because if you're just interviewing them
nothing happens absolutely and it may
not be wasted with cash if they can go
back to them and say hey I'm a mindset
coach like maybe there's a fit with what
you guys I'd love to put on a a mindset
event for you guys or something like you
could think about opportunities to work
with even within his own company his own
company his his customers something
right like him alone could you get 10
clients yeah that's true right with the
relationship yeah but only if he sees
the magic yes and the magic is harder to
strategize yeah so when you see
something
in your heart starts beating like oh my
God this is a thing my time you have to
you have to lean in on it yeah and do it
that's so true
I'm an investor in um
a publishing company called Joan of Arc
publishing and my partner Kira
it's basically all built off of her her
intuition her she tells people Channel
books
so it's a similar conversation like here
like your magic is not of your website
how do you even explain what you do they
need to feel it I need to do it but you
need to be bold and be brave and feel
safe to do the thing
and so she was at um
I'd even call this place like they do
ice baths and saunas and Whole Health
kind of yeah so she's there and then she
sees a guy and she starts talking to him
and then she she realizes hey this guy's
got a book in him and at the sauna
whatever puts her hand under his heart
and like channels his book for him
and now he's looking at becoming a
client he's he wants like I want to
introduce you to all these people who
could but like you can never plan for
that what's the strategy go to Asana and
touch random half naked men you know
it's like it's not a it's not us it
could work for a woman yeah well if
you're the wrong people but that is
where the heart takes over right it's
like your gifts will show up in an
unexpected way that you can't strategize
for we're just creating the environment
for them to come up but it requires you
to be courageous and bold right in the
session to call something out and go
deeper because people don't
it's an uncomfortable thing to start
sharing some of those things right
um so it's like you can't strategize for
it but you'll know it when you feel it
right and it's easy to suppress our
gifts because we're worried and that's
like you have to lean in on it so that
like Kasha could have had an amazing
experience with you about
something around mindset but but we
didn't do it now we're thinking about it
you know you're right you're right and
it's not it's not lost either like you
have the relationship you can always
absolutely go round two or say what
you're doing and maybe there's a
connection with his clients too right so
it's not a loss opportunity but
you know that's the immediate plan
if you if you if you were doing three
shows a week
with ideal clients or ideal referral
partners and you're you're creating
Magic on the show
you'll get your five 100 right yeah or
you get your ten or like whatever you
actually want or need or can handle
right which I mean you have to lean off
the show at some point because you will
you don't want to be coaching
every day all day long like even when
you leave your job you won't want to be
doing coaching right like some but not
all day yeah and that's where you know
you could build a three four five
hundred thousand dollar a year coaching
business right just off of coaching just
off of coaching but then that'll be too
small because you've got much bigger
yeah change the world yes I do that 300
000 income allows you to hire somebody
to help you start doing all this other
stuff which then generates other income
streams and like then we start building
the machine yes yeah but step one is get
out of the job get your five clients
seven clients ten clients right and
that's the fastest through the business
show biz Dev show yeah it's the path
angel I don't know if you connect with
Angel yes she sent me an email yesterday
so for the next 12 weeks you have her
resource too yeah so any questions
reviews problems yeah connect with her I
am
um
in our session in movie makers on
Thursdays final finalizing the biz Dev
show stop that's good so because it's
funny when I did my first live with you
a couple weeks ago it was like this deaf
is deaf but I was in a mental block like
well who's my ideal like like who do I
go to who can help me and I just I had
such a block because I think I was
focused on the wrong things and in the
wrong sequence yeah so I can but this
this gives me so much Clarity on where I
need to be focusing my energy and my
efforts yeah again you have the lists
yeah
that's the 5 000 people on that list not
maybe not all of them are ideal but
there's there's enough to go on yeah
they're all entrees who want more
promotion rang favorite of them the
hardest one of having your first guest
he was amazing yeah yeah now it's hard
emotionally but you're the mindset coach
so you can work yourself out of it of oh
I already invested all this time into my
website and my social media content and
I feel like I'm abandoning it and and
it's just not now that's all we're going
to come back to it it doesn't mean you
have to completely stop if you like it
if it's fun whatever it's just a
sub-optimal way to get to your goal yeah
well I mean I'm not I'm not in love with
it right I feel like it's just more work
right having to learn everything and
understand how this machine works and
the algorithms and and it's like taking
me so much further away from what I
really want to be doing yeah right but
then the business show is something that
I can put out there and create that
opportunity for myself to like pause ask
a question you know lean into like
people will tell you what they're doing
but how often do people actually ask you
about you right they ask you about what
you do but what about who you are
or how you became what you became mine
said Mary right thank you
great yeah because like you know and
people love to be asked questions about
them because people don't nearly ask
these questions enough right everybody's
so busy being busy that nobody really
stops to just really say hey how are you
you know what's going on in your mind
how can I help
sounds like a good show
let's go thank you Mary so um since
we're here and I'm thinking Evan would
you like to be on my show
let's do it
not right now because we got one minute
to go but I mean I mean you know
afterwards yeah afterwards I'd love to
have you lean on the magic oh thank you
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe see you there